so uh hello again I'm Keith Soros my
colleague Peter today were going to be
talking kind of about something that's
really related to the previous
conversation I think about missing data
errors and data that we found and how
we're tackling those problems and how
we're putting them into a like kind of a
live production environment so quick
overview the presentation going to talk
about panjiva super briefly the
importance of the data that were going
to be talking about and then our
solutions and how we're applying them
directly in our production environment
so what does panjiva who is panjiva
whichever you prefer basically we're a
company that's mapping the network of
global trade so we receive a lot of
information from disparate sources most
notably government's customs debarments
trade data from the United States China
Mexico Brazil a number of other
countries all in all that information
allows us to map entities between around
190 countries because of the data that's
contained within it covering six hundred
million transactional records of trade
international trade and seven million
distinct company entities the first
thing that we do and we talked a little
bit about this last year and I talk
about it every day as my colleagues kind
of test is that we pull in a lot of data
sources and they're heterogeneous and
they're dirty and they're messy and I
think everyone kind of deals with that
sort of situation and we structure them
and make them actionable at these
transaction kind of micro level records
so we have information on parties that
are conducting trade these actors we
have information on what they're doing
who is assisting them in conducting the
transaction so maybe shipping lines
vessel operators and what they're
actually doing sometimes we even have
information on the economic impact such
as taxes assessed by various governments
the cost of the goods the cost of the
freight and as you can imagine this
actually gives a really powerful window
into business operations for the for
these companies so with that in mind the
next thing that we do and we talked
about this a lot last year was roll up
this transactional data into company
profiles that allow us to combine the
over 30 data sources that we have into
kind of research centers for an
individual company and more recently and
the thing we're be talking about today
is our ability to then fix the errors
that we find systemically in the data
kind of in an automated and very quick
fashion to conduct and create these
networks from the different company
profiles that allow you to
explore the flow of goods around the
world in different supply chains or kind
of arbitrarily design defined tread
chains so the importance of data that
were that we're going to be talking
about right now it was a really great
conversation on missing erroneous data
correcting it understanding the damage
or or not that you could be doing to
your original data and obviously this is
a vital importance to us because people
are making pretty expensive decisions
based on the information that we provide
to them so theoretically what is our
goal here it's to allow our customers
and our internal analysts because we
also have researchers at our firm to
basically have real-world statistical
analysis capability on our data the data
comes in every day it's an enormous
amount millions of records a day and we
want to make sure that they're corrected
and able to be researched immediately
when they're living on the platform and
the primary obstacle of course is that a
lot of this is missing and there are
errors in it and it's not just errors
that happen from transcription or errors
that happen accidentally it could be
things that are actually intelligently
introduced into these these data sets as
an attempt to defraud or an attempt to
hide or obfuscated activity so we're
battling that as well and we're going to
discuss our three primary solutions the
three category is a problem that we've
seen so far which are the missing
observations so I think something
Anthony is always great at discussing
which is knowing what you don't know
missing values when you figure out what
you don't know and incorrect values and
how they impact aggregate analysis even
with small errors at the micro level
I'll talk a little bit about missing
observations first so are our three
steps that appears oh is outlining for
me or to detect correct and enable
that's kind of we like to do things in
steps of three at our company so
detecting for us we receive trade data
its transactional and a lot of its date
bounded so we want to identify periods
where there seems to be something wrong
with the information that we're getting
from governments and as you can imagine
government data comes in comes in fits
and bursts it's very fickle because it's
subject to changing laws changing
opinions on public privacy company
privacy it's subject to changes in
regime all of these things make it
really interesting to review when trade
is increasing decreasing or staying flat
from a particular source so
one of the things that we want to do for
correction is we're going to treat these
periods that seem anonymous seem weird
seem like they might be causing problems
in our aggregate analysis as missing
values right off the bat we're just
going to say these are missing let's
construct a model to understand what
would happen if they weren't and then
we're going to attempt to correct that
by kind of taking a principled approach
to these abnormal periods and I'll show
you what that looks like live so this is
an example of one of the things that
we're looking at especially with record
counts even though this is applicable to
a kind of a broad variety of problems on
the Left you'll see we're running a
search we're just looking over all of
the different government data sources
that we have for transactional shipment
records and you'll notice that there are
almost 700,000 individual transactions
over a particular time period this kind
of 2008 to present time period that's
being outlined on a chart to the right
and you'll notice that about five
hundred and seventy eight thousand of
them are from the United States well
this is really interesting and if you
notice on the right hand side we're
talking about Walmart here so everyone's
familiar with them they're a huge
company a lot of important export
activity all over the world very
organized supply chain 700,000 seems
kind of normal for them based on other
research but if we look on the right if
we just were to look at information that
was provided directly from the US
government that is specifically saying
this is something that belongs to
walmart this is an activity thats
related to walmart we only have 173 ops
or 173,000 observations during the same
period and what our system is actually
doing here is automatically flagging
based on that knowledge and knowledge of
other areas domain expertise in this
particular case for opt out manifest
confidentiality requests that there were
periods two periods in fact where we
believe that Walmart is conducting some
type of opt out or manifest
confidentiality requests they've
requested some form of transaction
hiding from the customs department which
they can do here and we're able to kind
of look beyond that opt out by one using
the other data sources in our data set
and to searching around the things that
normally we would search through we also
flag it automatically for our customers
right on the platform so you talk about
missing values I'll turn it over to
Peter sure yeah so that was great thanks
Keith for the introduction so Keith's
just been talking about missing
observations in the case we have a
missing
value as the previous presentation just
alluded to you have a field in which you
have values that are missing you know
that that field should exist you have
the observation but even the field is
pretty sparse or you're missing values
even if it's not sparse in a way that
will potentially impact your analysis
what we want to do is you want to impute
these missing values and we can't have a
measure of confidence as was alluded to
before and what this is going to enable
is it's going to enable unbiased and
efficient analysis by this I mean if we
don't if we just discard these
observations for the analysis that
relies upon this field we're going to be
making the assumption that this data is
missing completely at random you're just
going to be saying it's unrelated to all
the other variables in my data set and
that's almost certainly incorrect if we
impute these values we can get away from
this and we can make an assumption as
long as we assume that we can imputed
based upon other values in the data set
then we're going to be enabling a much
more unbiased and an efficient analysis
or amusing more of our data and we're
not preferentially going to be
discarding data that falls into some
sort of class this will allow us both to
do analysis but it'll also allow us to
query and investigate individual records
so in our case this is public record
data and people have an interest not
only in doing aggregate analysis but
also looking at individual records so
it's helpful as well just to have a full
record at that level even if you're
doing nothing further so I'm going to
give an example so one thing that's
important for us on our site is product
categories if you're familiar with
international trade a common ontology
system is the is the HTS or HS code
system for the purposes of this talk all
you really need to know is that it's a
international system for categorizing
physical goods as you can see on the
site we we have a lot of different data
and it's in a lot of different languages
so if you were looking for for example
data on shirts on our site well some of
our customs data is in Spanish so maybe
you want to search camisa and you can
see here that then we end up with /
imports being the primary import data
source that refers to shirts as defined
as camisa if you do it in English you'll
see that the u.s. is now the primary
import source as information on short
ports this is leaving the side any other
question about synonyms for shirt even
within language so maybe shirts are
being referred to as blouses for example
so if you don't have some sort of
product ontology system constructed then
you're going to end up in a pretty tight
spot you better be thinking pretty clear
Phylly about that boolean logic to find
all those shirts shipments that you're
interested in however if we can put them
all in a common category system we're
going to be in a better spot the u.s.
import data is a good example of a data
source that does that rarely comes with
this product category system it rarely
has an HTS code however we can put that
in so here we see an example of used
cars coming into the u.s. their toyota
cars they're coming from japan now they
don't come with an HTS code they don't
come with this product category we'd
like to have it if we have it we can
then search for this data set and then
also through our mexico data set for
example and find shipments just by that
code and here we see that we've done
that here we've imputed the value and
you can see it's a category 8703 which
i'm sure means a lot to everybody and
that's correct so that that's then that
will enable is so that will enable all
these types of analysis just both micro
and macro that we just talked about
moving on to erroneous values we can end
up in a situation where we just have
erroneous values in the data it just
comes from a lot of different sources i
mean our data is coming from ports often
at its root a lot of there's a lot of
there's both systematic and misrepresent
and there's also just a lot of weirdness
at ports and people filling out forms
and languages they don't necessarily
speak very well just all sorts of
capabilities for data entry errors is
then put into a databases so there's a
lot of just different transmission a lot
of potential for air introduction and in
fact we do see that in our data you will
find shipments that are just enormously
large they were there two hundred times
the largest ship in the world it doesn't
make sense and it's going to distort
your analysis so we need to detect these
then once we've got them we need to do
impute the correct value or do some sort
of domain-specific fix you can really
look at your own application for
thinking about the weight best way to
handle the situation but you want to be
aware of it this is going to enable
analysis both at the micro and macro
what I mean by this is referring back to
your previous slide you've got this
shipment of cars you'd like to sometimes
look at that individual shipment because
you're very interested in what happened
on that day because i don't know maybe
they're one of the parties involved you
want to see what the public record of
that day is maybe you've got other
reasons or maybe you want to do an
overall analysis of car imports into the
u.s. you want the weight to be correct
you want that aggregate analysis to be
correct so both micro and macro and what
we can do then if we do this right is we
can minimize outliers not by aggregating
everything in the discarding points that
look wrong for this aggregate analysis
but actually starting from the micro
level and then ending up with a macro
analysis that doesn't have those
outliers and will be in a better spot so
here we see an example of an oil
shipment of Arab light crude coming into
the US where the weight greatly exceeded
the large group of the capacity of a
large bulk ship so it's about I mean
it's about 200 large ships of oil coming
to the u.s. ostensibly are all on this
one it's really not great this ship is
not right and also because oil comes in
very large shipments you're going to end
up in a situation where this is going to
destroy an overall analysis of imports
into the u.s. certainly for oil and
possibly for other things on this day
certainly in one port however we can fix
that and we fixed it here so you know
we've detected this error it seems
pretty obvious and then we've actually
corrected it and if you look at the
number of barrels if you're familiar
with oil and just I'm just kidding but
if you you know if you do the
calculations you'll find that it is it
is the correct weight then we go on to
the macro level analysis this allows us
to remove points that are manifestly
unrealistic not through discarding them
as outliers but rather after the
corrections just not having them anymore
so here we see imports into the u.s.
from Australia and we see on the right
in the circle bit a series of imports in
which 200 to 2,000 of larger ships in
the world docked in a single day in the
US and it's not like Australia is like
moving to the US in one large group it's
not happening that's not what actually
that's incorrect however when we when we
do carry out this correction at the
train
action level we end up with data we this
will actually disappear the distribution
also slightly shifts a little bit to the
left but the main the main effect you
would see if I put that up there as
that's just it's gone and it's not gone
because we discarded it it's gone
because our data is now more correct so
missing no more that's that's what
that's what we're going for and yeah so
if you have any more questions and we
can answer them now there's the round
table after really excited about this
we're really interested to hear what
you're doing and we could just talk
about it so I'm here this Keith and
that's our presentation